cardinality is the word that's used to
refer to the size of infinite sets and
before we go further let's take a quick
look at why we're interested in infinite
sets in a course that's mathematics for
computer scientists why does computer
science care about infinite says well
you know like every data structure that
you'd examine in computer memory is
finite and the integers individually are
finite you only calculate with finite
things but the infinite abstraction
happens right at the beginning although
any given integer is finite the set of
all integers is infinite and although
any given matrix is finite a set of all
the matrices that might be represented
in a computation
I'll find out an infinite set so we we
take infinite sets for granted and
reason about them all the time
the second from a pedagogical point of
view introducing the concept of infinite
sets and reasoning about them carefully
forces you to go beyond your intuition
and really follow the rules and reason
in a careful mathematical way because
although some properties that you're
familiar with from finite sets carry
over to infinite sets others don't and
in order to know which is which you have
to be thinking carefully about the rules
and properties that they have as opposed
to just going by intuition and familiar
properties and finally the reasoning
that goes goes into comparing the sizes
of infinite sets which is the topic of
today's video has profound implications
in computer science because it leads to
the insight of ethological limits of
computation and examples of specific
problems that computers can't solve
which we'll be taking up in a later
video but for now let's go back to the
topic of cardinality so there was this
mathematician in the 19th century late
19th century named Cantor who was
actually working on
a 40 a series and he discovered that the
the kind of series that he was working
with diverged an infinity of many places
which sounds kind of bad but he wanted
to get across the idea that it didn't
diverge it very many infinite places and
that led him to this idea of comparing
the sizes of infinite sets so this is
Cantor's idea will you know from the
mapping lemma that if you're looking at
finite sets a and B then the size of a
is greater than or equal to the size of
B if and only if a surge B where surges
this technical relation which means
there exists a surjective function from
A to B that is a function with greater
than or equal to one arrow into every
element of B and Cantor's idea was say
well it works fine for finite sets why
don't we take this as the definition of
what we mean by a is at least the size
of B for infinite sets so we're gonna
think of a surge B now as saying a is as
big as big and for finite sets we can
it's literally true that a surge B if
and only if the size of a is greater
than or equal to the size of B now let
me take a moment to say that this notion
of size or cardinality when you're
talking about infinite sets it's kind of
a no no there's a an abstract concept of
the of what cardinal numbers are what
these infinite numbers are but the truth
is they're technical and not a very much
use so we will never actually be talking
about the cardinality or size of an
infinite set but what we will do is
compare them we're going to have a nice
elementary theory of the idea that the
cardinality of one set is greater than
or equal to the cardinality of another
set and the basic definition is going to
be based on surge similarly by ejection
is even easier on a by B means that
there's a bisection from A to B and
we're going to interpret that as saying
that a and B of the same size that is
for finite sets it literally means a and
B have the same number of elements and
we're going to adopt the notion of a by
jected relation for infinite sets as
meaning okay
I don't know what their size is but I
know it's the same because there's a
bisection between them there's a perfect
one-to-one correspondence between a is
and B's um
let's look at an example of where by
Jack she comes up the power set of n if
n is the non-negative integers the power
set of n is all the subsets of
non-negative integers and let me just
remark that there's an obvious by
ejection between the subsets of integers
and the infinite bit strings the
infinite strings of zeros and ones so n
is the set of non-negative integers 0 1
2 if you take any subset of and here's
one with a 0 missing one has 2 & 3
missing 4 5 has 6 and so on then what I
can do is represent such a subset
possibly an infinite subset now by an
infinite sequence of ones and zeros put
in ones in the position where elements
in the subset occur and zeros in
positions where elements don't occur
this was exactly the same logic ssin
that we had found between the
non-negative the bitstrings and the
subs' and the finite subsets of the
non-negative integers but now we're just
extending it to arbitrary subsets of the
non-negative integers so this defines a
bisection between any subset of integers
corresponds to an infinite bit strings
and conversely from any infinite
different you can reconstruct what
subset it refers to so here's this
notation 0 1 to the Omega meaning the
infinite bit strings that are infinite
to the right they have a beginning in
comparison to 0 1 superscript star which
refers to the finite set some districts
so now let's examine the standard size
properties that you'd expect if these
relationships of surgeon behaved like
relationships between sizes so one basic
property that finite sizes have is that
if a is equal to billion B is equal to C
in size then the size of a and the size
of say are the same that's certainly
true for finite sets does it hold for
infinite sets where now equality is
going to be replaced by by well we have
to
is it true that if a by HB and B by C
implies a by C well how do you prove
that well it's true and here's how by
definition since a by CH B that means
that you have a bisection F G from A to
B and since B by C you have a bisection
F from B to C now I need from these two
by ejections that I'm given I need to
find a bisection between a and C well
that's easy what you do is you use G to
go from A to B and then you use F to go
from B to C and you compose them and
that gives you the needed by ejection
from A to C so you find H to be the
composition of F and G and it's easy to
check that if G and F or by sections
then their composition is a bisection so
that's how I find the needed by ejection
from A to C so this property works out
just fine
the similar property applies to at least
as big as greater than or equal to four
finite sets if a is greater equal to b
and b is great length of C in size then
a is great an equal to C and actually
the same argument that worked for equal
for budget works for search because the
composition of surjection of surjective
functions is a surjective function so if
a search b and b search c implies a
search see now again remember although
we're thinking of surges meaning greater
than or equal to in size you cannot take
these size properties for granted they
have to be proved search has a technical
definition having to do with surjective
functions functions with greater equal
to one arrow in that is not the same as
talking about equality of some kind of
sizes well let's look at an example
where the designs properties hold but
they're less obvious because here's a
another familiar size property if a and
B are each of size greater three go for
the other one then they're the same size
so if the size of a is greater equal to
the size of B and the size of being a
screaming over the size of a then a and
B of the same size now this is certainly
true for finite says it's kind of you
don't even think about the fact
and it holds for infinite sets but it's
not so obvious so what we're saying is
that if I have a surjective function
from A to B and I have another
surjective function from B to a then
there's a bisection between a and B and
the problem here is that this surjection
from A to B might not be a buy action
and this surjection from B to a might
also not be a buy ejection so where's
the buy action going to come from I have
to build it and so this is not an
obvious property it's true it's called
the Schroder Bernstein's theorem and the
trick basically is you take the buy
ejection from A to B and the by GX u
from B to a and you take parts of one
and combine it with parts of the other
and in a slightly ingenious way that
actually is contained in a problem in
the text you can find the buy action
from A to B but it does take a little
bit of ingenuity so this is a SCI's
property that works for surge and bodge
but it's you can't say it's obvious well
let's look at an unfamiliar sized
property something that's not true of
finite sets where we have to start being
careful and not just hand-wave and use
our intuition about finite sets namely
for infinite sizes size plus 1 is equal
to size now what exactly does that mean
well let's just illustrate it with an
example in fact in some ways you could
say the definition of an infinite set is
that its size plus 1 is equal to its
size let's look at a simple example so
on the bottom I have the non-negative
integers and on the top I have the
positive integers so I can get from the
positive integers to the non-negative
integers just by throwing in 0 so that's
where the plus 1 comes from here's a
nice infinite set I add another element
to it and I get another infinite set but
they are the same size I have to show a
by ejection between them to show they're
the same size well you know what the
bisection is map 0 to 1 1 to 2 2 to 3
this is a bijection which you know as
the a drum function the N 1 function
Maps the non-negative integers to the
positive integers and it's a perfect
projection there for adding one element
to the non
of integers to the positive integers
does not get me a larger set it gets me
another set of the same size and this
argument actually generalizes to any
infinite set if you throw in one extra
element you could still find a bisection
between the original set and the set
with one extra element so and is the
same size as the positive integers well
in fact let's look at this one I can
enumerate on the top all the integers
both positive and negative right 0 1
minus 1 2 minus 2 and so on and that
gives me the set consisting of all the
interviews and over here I can have 0 1
2 just the non-negative integers and you
can see the orderly way in which I've
listed the integers at the top that
implicitly defines a bisection I'm going
to map 0 to the zeroth element of the of
the sequence above 1 to 1 to 2 minus 1 3
to 2 4 to minus 2 and in this way I
actually defined a bijection between the
non-negative integers and all the
integers in other words you take a half
of the integers namely the non-negative
integers and it's still the same size as
all of them there's a bisection between
N and C now before you could write a
formula actually if you were trying to
figure out what does the number n go to
what a positive or negative integer
there's some not very hard formula
involving dividing n by 2 and rounding
but that doesn't matter once I figured
out some sensible way to list all the
elements of the integers in a row then I
can line them up against the
non-negative integers and and that
listing in effect defines the mapping in
a perfectly clear way without
necessarily having a formula